MEANING, OF COURSE, THE WALL
ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
JUDGE?
>> Judge: ED, THANKS SO
MUCH.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> Judge: HURT.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION
IS FORMER PRESS SECRETARY
FOR VICE PRESIDENT PENCE,
MARC LOTTER AND FORMER OBAMA
ECONOMIC ADVISOR AUSTAN
GOOLSBEE.
ALL RIGHT, GOOD EVENING,
GENTLEMEN, MARK, I WILL
START WITH YOU, THE
PRESIDENT CERTAINLY HAS A
LOT TO TALK ABOUT, 14
MONTHS, 15 MONTHS IN WITH
ALL OF THE NUMBERS THAT HE
TALKED ABOUT WITH
UNEMPLOYMENT AND JOBS AND
3 MILLION NEW JOBS SINCE
ELECTION DAY.
I MEAN, THERE IS PRETTY MUCH
A VERY POSITIVE MESSAGE.
IT'S KIND OF INTERESTING
THAT THERE WOULD BE ANY
RESISTANCE TOWARDS HIS
EFFORT AT LEAST TO CREATE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE EFFORT
THAT APPARENTLY IS STALLED
IN CONGRESS.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
>> WELL, IT'S BASICALLY WHAT
YOU JUST SAID.
IT'S RESULTS VERSUS
RESISTANCE.
AND, IN THIS CASE.
HE IS TALKING ABOUT BUILDING
AN EVEN BETTER AMERICA
AGAIN.
THAT'S WHERE HIS FOCUS IS.
HE TOOK THAT MESSAGE RIGHT
INTO THE HEART OF BLUE
COLLAR OHIO.
HE IS GOING TO TAKE IT
AROUND THE COUNTRY FOR THE
NEXT OF THE THREE YEARS.
THAT'S THE PLATFORM IS HE
GOING TO MOVE THIS COUNTRY
FORWARD WITH.
>> Judge: AUSTAN, YOU WOULD
AGREE, WOULDN'T YOU, THAT
OUR ROADS AND BRIDGES ARE
CERTAINLY IN NEED OF REPAIR
AND YET ARE, THE DEMOCRATS,
AS MARK INDICATED CONTINUE
TO RESIST.
THIS IS NOT A POLITICAL
ISSUE.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY COME
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE REPAIR OUR ROADS AND
BRIDGES AND GET A BETTER
INFRASTRUCTURE?
>> WELL, I DO AGREE WITH
YOU.
I THOUGHT -- HE OUGHT TO
HIRE YOU GUYS TO CLEAN UP
HIS SPEECHES.
THE ACTUAL SPEECH THERE WAS
YOU MADE IT A LOT MORE
COHERENT AND ON MESSAGE.
HE WAS ALL OVER THE PLACE.
I MEAN, IS HE TALKING ABOUT
ROSEANNE AND TALKING ABOUT
NORTH KOREA.
ON INFRASTRUCTURE IT'S NOT
JUST THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Judge: AUSTAN, YOU KNOW
WHAT?
I HAVE TO INTERRUPT YOU.
THEY LOVE HIM FOR THAT.
THAT'S WHY HE GOT ELECTED.
>> OKAY.
YOU MAY BE RIGHT.
BUT, ON THE ISSUE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE, IT'S NOT
JUST THE DEMOCRATS HOLDING
HIM UP.
WHAT'S GOING WRONG IS THE
PRESIDENT'S INFRASTRUCTURE
PLAN IS NOT ACTUALLY A PLAN
FOR FEDERAL INCREASE IN
SPENDING ON INFRASTRUCTURE
OF THE SIZE HE IS TALKING
ABOUT.
HE IS TRYING IN HIS PLAN TO
PUT THE COST ONTO THE STATE
AND EVEN THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS ARE SAYING THEY
DON'T WANT TO DO THAT PLAN.
SO THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
HE HAS GOT TO FIND MORE OF A
COMMON GROUND.
>> Judge: MARK?
>> INFRASTRUCTURE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN A FEDERAL, STATE, LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP.
AND WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
TALKING ABOUT DOING IS
TAKING $200 BILLION AND
USING THAT TO LEVERAGE
LOCAL, STATE, PRIVATE SECTOR
MONEYS TO THE TUNE OF
1.5 TRILLION.
AND THAT'S THE WAY WE SHOULD
BE DOING IT.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THERE ARE
TOO MANY STATES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, ESPECIALLY IN
SOME OF THE AREAS IN THE
NORTHEAST THAT THEY GET MOST
OF THEIR MONEY FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THEY
JUST JUST GO AHEAD AND WASTE
IT.
IF THEY PUT MORE SKIN IN THE
GAME THEN MAYBE THEY WILL BE
BETTER STEWARDS OF THAT
MONEY AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE PROJECTS GET BUILT
ONTIME, UNDER BUDGET AND
THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
FOCUSED ON.
>> OKAY.
I DON'T AGREE WITH THAT THAT
WAS NOT A CORRECT STATEMENT.
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY